Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
你好，我是 Marianne。在进入今天的内容之前，我想先向大家预告一件令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾想过如何创造属于自己的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师 Lisa Johnson 发起的“Race to Recurring Revenue”挑战。这项挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Coming up in today's episode, we are looking at what it is like to live with complex
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有机会赢取由 Lisa 本人提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent 博士进行一对一辅导的机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的 Linktree 页面（Dr. Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。在今天的节目中，我们将探讨患有复杂
pain, what it is like to be a wheelchair user, and some of the struggles that they might navigate as they navigate the profession of psychology with those additional challenges. I hope you find it so useful. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent, and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. Now, I have started learning a little bit more about podcasting really as I've gone along. And it was as I was recording an episode with Gavin, which you might well have listened to recently, which was all about master's level study, that I started thinking, oh, I think this other topic we've gone on to might well best operate as a separate episode, because I was thinking about something called search engine optimization, which you might have
疼痛是什么样的体验，作为轮椅使用者是什么样的感受，以及他们在从事心理学职业时可能会遇到的挑战。希望这些内容对你有所帮助。你好，欢迎收听《Aspiring Psychologist》播客。我是 Marianne Trent 博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。其实，我在做播客的过程中也在不断学习。就在我录制与 Gavin 的那一期关于硕士水平学习的节目时（你可能最近刚听过），我开始思考，我们谈到的另一个话题或许作为单独的一期节目会更好，因为我当时在想“搜索引擎优化”，你可能
heard called SEO. so we decided we were going to have two episodes so two for the price of one so if you might find it useful to listen to gavin's previous episode please do you can watch that either on youtube or listen to it as an mp3 across loads of platforms including, including Apple, and also directly from my website, www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk forward slash podcasts. Whilst you're there, you might like to also download some of my lovely free lead magnets, one of which is the Ultimate Declin Sci Guide. You can get to that by going to my website and then looking at the free resources
听说过它叫 SEO。所以我们决定录制两期节目，相当于买一送一。如果你觉得听 Gavin 的上一期节目很有用，请务必去听听。你可以在 YouTube 上观看，也可以在包括 Apple 在内的各大平台上收听 MP3 版本，或者直接访问我的网站 www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk/podcasts。在访问网站时，你可能还会想下载我那些很棒的免费引流资源，其中之一就是《Ultimate Declin Sci Guide》。你可以通过访问我的网站，然后查看“免费资源”
tab, which will be either on the right of the screen as you look on desktop, or if you're on mobile, if you click the little, what they call burger icon, it should pop down and you can scroll until you find the sweet spot. So let's think today about welcoming Gavin back. And we're going to be thinking with him about pain, about being a wheelchair user. You might find it useful to listen if you are affected by some of the things that Gavin is experiencing or similar, or just to kind of thicken your narrative and your understanding of some of these very important issues. If you are working in the sphere of mental health. I will look forward to catching up with you on the other side.
标签页找到它。在电脑端，它位于屏幕右侧；如果你在手机上，点击那个所谓的“汉堡图标”，它应该会弹出来，你可以滚动页面直到找到它。那么，今天让我们欢迎 Gavin 回归。我们将与他探讨疼痛、轮椅使用者的生活。如果你受到 Gavin 所经历的类似情况的影响，或者只是想加深对这些重要议题的叙述和理解，那么这期节目对你来说会很有用。如果你在心理健康领域工作，我期待在节目后与你交流。
If you're watching on YouTube, why not just like the video right away because we know it's going to be a good one. See you very soon. So Gavin, I want to welcome you back to the podcast. It was when we were recording the previous version and we were like, I think this might almost be two separate episodes. thank you so much for agreeing to to come back again
如果你正在 YouTube 上观看，为什么不直接点赞呢？因为我们知道这会是一期精彩的节目。很快再见。那么 Gavin，欢迎回到播客。我们在录制上一期节目时就觉得，这几乎可以分成两期独立的节目。非常感谢你愿意再次回来。
no no not at all it was it was really enjoyable the first time around uh so why not come back and talk some more tell us a little bit about yourself for those who might not have caught the first episode? Yeah, so my name is Gavin Clark. I am an MSc Psychology student. I'm a podcast host. And I also work in my kind of day job as a compliance manager, which sounds very grandiose. But it's basically about making sure
不，一点也不麻烦，第一次录制非常愉快，所以为什么不回来多聊聊呢？对于那些可能没听过第一期节目的听众，请简单介绍一下你自己吧？好的，我叫 Gavin Clark。我是一名心理学硕士生，也是一名播客主持人。我的日常工作是合规经理，听起来很宏大，但本质上就是确保
that people are doing the right thing by by customers and and acting in the right sort of way um i live with disability um and i have done since birth and that's been a kind of story throughout my life of different experiences and and different kind of joyous moments uh along with some frustrating ones too. Yeah thank you for sharing that so the earlier episode we did was about kind of doing conversion masters and doing that in a distance learning capacity and I think that's going to be so useful but we wanted to get together today to think about your experiences of being a wheelchair user of trying to navigate through your career with that and also of some of the more unusual but incredibly difficult physical health conditions
人们以正确的方式对待客户，并以恰当的方式行事。我患有残疾，从出生起就是这样。这贯穿了我的一生，包含了各种不同的经历和快乐的时刻，当然也有一些令人沮丧的时刻。是的，谢谢你的分享。我们之前的那期节目是关于攻读转换硕士课程以及远程学习的，我认为那非常有价值。但我们今天想聚在一起，探讨你作为轮椅使用者的经历，尝试带着这些挑战在职业生涯中前行，以及你所经历的一些虽然罕见但极其困难的身体健康状况。
that you've struggled with yeah and there's a there's a lot to go through. And hopefully people listening find it interesting and insightful. I like to share some of the experiences that I have so that others can learn from them and maybe even realise something about ourselves in the process. So I was born with something called congenital talapaz equinovirus, CTAV. You might also see it named club feet, but please do not use that terminology because it's really offensive. So CTAV is the go-to, in my opinion. And basically what that means is that I had lots of surgeries when I was younger, lots of experiences of pain. That leads to a kind of dimension of trauma and just
是的，有很多内容可以聊。希望听众们觉得有趣且有启发。我喜欢分享我的一些经历，这样其他人可以从中学习，甚至在这个过程中对自己有新的认识。我出生时患有一种叫“先天性马蹄内翻足”（CTAV）的疾病。你可能也见过它被称为“内翻足”（club feet），但请不要使用这个术语，因为它非常冒犯。在我看来，CTAV 是首选称呼。简单来说，这意味着我小时候做过很多手术，经历过很多痛苦。这导致了一种创伤维度，而且
to experiences as you as you grow up surgery is not fun it's not a nice experience particularly when you're a when you're a baby and then you know two three years old 10 years old 15 years old all those kind of experiences add up and it kind of brings you to a point where you just understand things slightly more not necessarily at that age but actually as you grow older and kind of see how other people deal with different different things and you have that broadened experience you can pull more from uh from your own past experience and you can either use that or or you or you don't um and that's kind of personal opinion uh kind of personal standpoint um whether you feel capable of of using that or not because for some that they just can't it's just it's just not something they can do i'm again very fortunate
随着你的成长，手术并不好玩，也不是什么愉快的经历，尤其是当你还是个婴儿，然后是两三岁、十岁、十五岁的时候，所有这些经历累积起来，让你对事情有了更深刻的理解。不一定是在那个年纪，但随着你长大，看到别人如何处理不同的事情，你有了更广阔的经验，你可以从自己的过去中汲取更多。你可以利用这些经历，或者不利用，这取决于个人观点和立场，看你是否觉得有能力去利用它。因为对有些人来说，他们就是做不到，这只是他们无法做到的事情。我再次感到非常幸运，
that i am able to to kind of use some of that to at least try and help try and help others to to work through their experiences too. Thank you very much thanks for illuminating us a little bit have you always been a wheelchair user? So no I started using a wheelchair about two years ago. This will probably show you some of my stubbornness in life. So I've had periods where I could do a lot more. And even now I have some periods where I can do more, that I can kind of get up and walk around. And I'm what's called an ambulatory wheelchair user.
我能够利用其中的一部分，至少尝试去帮助其他人克服他们的经历。非常感谢，感谢你的启发。你一直都是轮椅使用者吗？不是的，我大约两年前开始使用轮椅。这可能体现了我生活中固执的一面。我曾有过能做更多事情的时期。即使是现在，我也有一些时期能做更多，比如我可以站起来走动。我被称为“行走轮椅使用者”。
And what that means is that I'm someone that can actually get themselves up out of the chair and move around to a certain extent whereas a kind of permanent wheelchair user would be somebody perhaps that had a spinal injury that kind of had some spinal cord damage and just cannot physically walk or kind of move themselves around in any kind of meaningful way without the use of a wheelchair. So there are different types of people within that wheelchair user population, including people with kind of chronic fatigue syndromes and just energy limiting kind of conditions. So there's lots of reasons that people would use
这意味着我是一个实际上可以从椅子上站起来，并在一定程度上走动的人。而“永久轮椅使用者”可能是指那些脊髓受伤，导致脊髓受损，如果不使用轮椅就无法在物理上行走或以任何有意义的方式移动的人。所以，轮椅使用者群体中有不同类型的人，包括患有慢性疲劳综合征和能量受限疾病的人。所以人们使用轮椅的原因有很多。
wheelchairs i started using it after one of my latest operations um which was a couple of years ago um and that didn't go that well uh it was always a bit of a risk um i was kind of willing to take that risk because there was a good chance it was going to work, but it just left me in a worse position. That then developed the complex regional pain syndrome, or at least it's probably the kind of bit that tipped it over the edge from normal, well, I'm saying normal complex pain, complex pain that wasn't the kind of defined condition to um this this complex regional pain syndrome or crps and from that point really i've been using a mixture of wheelchair
我是在最近一次手术后开始使用轮椅的，那大约是两年前。手术不太成功，这总是有风险的。我当时愿意承担那个风险，因为很有可能成功，但结果却让我处于更糟糕的境地。那之后发展成了复杂区域疼痛综合征（CRPS），或者至少是那个让我从“正常”——我指的是“复杂疼痛”，即未定义条件的复杂疼痛——转变为这种复杂区域疼痛综合征的转折点。从那时起，我确实一直在混合使用轮椅、
kind of crutches i did try using a a walking stick that didn't work that well um this might show my age slightly but um for those of you that are old enough to remember house i basically had an image in my head that i would be like house uh kind of going around being slightly ratty um but getting away with it um the reality was i just kept on falling over uh which was not so good um so yeah i've kind of been using a mixture of things and more and more the wheelchair um so i use the wheelchair when i'm out and about um if i'm going into the office at work so i predominantly work from home at the moment um but if i'm going to the office i'll use the wheelchair just because I just can't physically get around that much. And if I try, I will probably end up falling, which is just not that much fun.
拐杖。我试过用手杖，但效果不好。这可能稍微暴露了我的年龄，但对于那些看过《豪斯医生》的人来说，我脑子里有个形象，就是我会像豪斯一样，有点刻薄，但能应付过去。现实情况是，我一直在摔倒，这可不太好。所以是的，我一直在混合使用各种辅助工具，而且越来越多地使用轮椅。我外出时会用轮椅，如果去办公室工作——我目前主要在家办公——但如果去办公室，我会用轮椅，因为我确实无法走动太多。如果我尝试走动，很可能会摔倒，那可一点也不好玩。
And yeah, you're always at risk of causing yourself some other injuries. Or I might just be so wiped out that i can't physically get back home because i i kind of have to drive back and people might be wondering how is a wheelchair user driving at that point um so i will just say that you know wheelchair users can drive um not all wheelchair users can it depends on what what their broader mobility is but i use hand controls to drive um so that kind of gives me my freedom i was without a car for about a year um whilst a mixture of the dvla were trying to sort themselves out not a fun experience trying to get that one sorted um and then just trying to get things fitted and and everything to to the car so i use that to kind of get around
而且，你总是面临造成其他伤害的风险。或者我可能会精疲力竭，以至于无法物理上回到家，因为我得开车回去。人们可能会好奇，轮椅使用者怎么开车？所以我只想说，轮椅使用者是可以开车的。并非所有轮椅使用者都可以，这取决于他们的整体活动能力，但我使用手控装置开车。这给了我自由。我曾有一年没有车，当时 DVLA（英国驾驶执照管理局）正试图理清自己的问题，处理那个过程可不是什么愉快的经历。然后就是尝试安装设备到车上，所以我用它来四处走动。
and having that that um freedom as i would describe it uh is incredibly important for me and for my own mental health so yeah i have had periods of depression i have had periods of of kind of being really very down really not wanting to be around anymore. And part of that was a lack of being able to do things. It was feeling like I was less than because I was having to rely on everybody else, despite having been born with an underlying genital condition that you know meant lots of pain over the years and use of crutches at some points and just not being able to keep up with other kids not being able to kind of do do everything that i wanted to um so yeah there's there's a kind of progression
拥有这种我所描述的“自由”，对我个人以及我的心理健康来说极其重要。所以是的，我经历过抑郁期，经历过非常低落、不想再活下去的时期。部分原因是无法做事情。尽管我天生患有潜在的先天性疾病，多年来经历了许多痛苦，有时需要使用拐杖，无法跟上其他孩子，无法做我想做的一切，但我还是感到自己不如别人，因为我不得不依赖其他人。所以是的，这是一种演变。
with um with the type of of condition that i've had. That kind of links in with then developing arthritis, which is very common when you've had the type of surgeries that I had as a youngster. And yeah, for those of you that have ever lived with arthritis or know somebody that does, you'll see that quite often it just gets worse. So I was always likely to end up needing to use a wheelchair. But bizarrely, I actually feel like the wheelchair
与我所患的疾病类型有关。这与后来发展的关节炎有关，这在你小时候做过我那种手术后非常常见。是的，对于那些曾经患有关节炎或认识患有关节炎的人来说，你会发现它通常只会变得更糟。所以我总是很可能最终需要使用轮椅。但奇怪的是，我实际上觉得轮椅
gives me opportunity so i know it's it can be very frustrating when you have people uh kind of talking to you in the kind of oh this is terrible you've got to use a wheelchair or even saying that you're wheelchair bound so i had an experience recently where i was going for an mri um and they couldn't do it because i was a wheelchair user and they they were kind of describing me as wheelchair bound now that sort of thing is is a kind of ableist um reaction to somebody that's just trying to live their life but the wheelchair for me gives me more experience gives me more freedom allows me to do things, allows me to get to the gym, lift big heavy it was appropriate for me to do it and actually it was because of therapy um that i kind of got to the point of really feeling like i could use mobility aids because my my therapist at the time who um was was fantastic um i was kind of
给了我机会。我知道，当人们用那种“哦，这太糟糕了，你必须用轮椅”的语气跟你说话，甚至说你是“轮椅束缚者”时，会非常令人沮丧。我最近有一次去拍核磁共振（MRI），他们因为我是轮椅使用者而无法进行检查，他们把我描述为“轮椅束缚者”。这种说法是对一个只想过自己生活的人的“能力歧视”反应。但对我来说，轮椅给了我更多体验，更多自由，让我能做事情，让我能去健身房，举起重物。如果这对我来说是合适的，那就去做。实际上，正是因为治疗，我才达到了真正觉得可以使用辅助工具的地步。因为我当时的治疗师非常棒，
seeing for probably about a year and a half and we were kind of talking about lots and lots of different things. But a lot of it came back to that I was struggling to do things. I was trying to kind of do what I'd always done and just find silly ways of being able to do what I thought was the expectation on me as a dad, as a human being, or as a citizen, when in reality, all I needed to do was to start using some mobility aids, let people help me a little bit more. But getting from one point to another of really not accepting that to accepting it
我看了大约一年半，我们谈论了很多不同的事情。但很多都归结为我难以做事情。我试图做我一直做的事情，试图找到愚蠢的方法来完成我认为作为父亲、作为一个人或作为公民对我的期望。但实际上，我所需要做的就是开始使用一些辅助工具，让人们多帮我一点。但从不接受这一点到接受它，需要一个过程。
you do need help and I think that's where I started to really think about okay it's it's time for me to rethink what I'm doing with my career as well as as well as anything else and started to kind of move towards the psychology side as well yeah it sounds like you sort of you'd noticed actually it was impacting on your ability to function and live your life as you wanted to and either you can carry on in that vein or you can kind of just do some accepting and embracing and then think that's not how I want to continue I want to have increased functionality I want to do all these things with my children in order to do that I'm going to need to start using that wheelchair embracing that yeah and it's acceptance really is freedom so and that sounds like such a grand statement doesn't it but it really is because as soon as you've started to accept particularly in that context of accepting that these things
你需要帮助，我认为这就是我开始真正思考的时候：是时候重新思考我的职业生涯以及其他一切了，并开始转向心理学方向。是的，听起来你注意到它实际上影响了你发挥功能和按你想要的方式生活的能力。要么你可以继续那样，要么你可以做一些接受和拥抱，然后认为这不是我想要继续的方式。我想要提高功能，我想和我的孩子们一起做所有这些事情，为了做到这一点，我需要开始使用轮椅，拥抱它。是的，接受确实就是自由。这听起来是一个宏大的陈述，不是吗？但它确实是。因为一旦你开始接受，特别是在接受这些东西的背景下，
these objects are just objects that facilitate me to do things that I want to do all they are all of ability aid is so once you accept that you then have the freedom to use them without guilt without feeling like you're less than like feeling like you don't belong you know all these kind of things that come up in your own mind um and that you formulate yourself because most of the stuff that i experienced was my own internal bias ultimately it was my own internalized ableism of thinking that oh if i hadn't move to using a wheelchair, then I'm properly disabled because I'd never really thought of myself as disabled prior to that.
这些物体只是促进我做我想做的事情的工具，这就是辅助工具的全部意义。所以一旦你接受了这一点，你就有自由去使用它们，没有内疚，没有觉得自己不如别人，没有觉得自己不属于那里，你知道，所有这些在你脑海中浮现的东西，以及你自己构思出来的东西。因为我经历的大部分事情都是我自己的内在偏见，归根结底是我自己内化的能力歧视，认为“哦，如果我没开始用轮椅，那我就是真正的残疾人”，因为在那之前我从未真正认为自己是残疾人。
I was by definition, but I never really thought of myself in that way. And it was that kind of acceptance period, whereas now I'm now in the position where I've just made it into the disability power 100 list as one of the 100 most influential disabled people in the uk um yeah i'm doing loads of stuff in in in work around uh increasing the the kind of um the career prospects and the the the way that people are treated in in in work who are who are disabled or neurodiverse um in particular or or just live with um i say just live with uh mental uh mental
从定义上讲我是，但我从未那样看待自己。这就是那个接受期。而现在，我已经进入了“残疾人权力 100 强”名单，成为英国 100 位最具影响力的残疾人之一。是的，我在工作中做了很多事情，围绕着提高残疾人或神经多样性人群的职业前景，以及他们在工作中受到的待遇。特别是，或者只是生活在……我说是“只是生活在”……心理
health conditions or or just going through a bad time for for that matter um and that's all because i got to the point where i could begin to accept that this is who I am and that that is okay. It wasn't a big deal. It was a freedom of being allowed to do the things that I want to go with my career is into psychology and is to to ultimately be able to help people in in a more kind of specific way that to work through their own um kind of self-limiting beliefs I guess to a certain extent but and the wider um collective of mental health uh problems conditions issues thank you that's soating. And thank you again for reminding me. I was told loud and clear
健康状况中，或者只是经历一段糟糕的时期。这一切都是因为我达到了可以开始接受“这就是我，这没关系”的地步。这不是什么大不了的事。这是一种被允许去做我想做的事情的自由。我的职业生涯转向了心理学，最终是为了能够以一种更具体的方式帮助人们，克服他们自己的自我限制信念，以及更广泛的心理健康问题。谢谢，这太有启发性了。再次感谢你的提醒。我被明确告知过，
when I was working with people with physical disabilities in the early 2000s, I am not wheelchair bound. I'm not like literally tied to this thing. I'm a wheelchair user and that's really stayed with me. But it is still something
当我在 2000 年代初与身体残疾人士一起工作时，“我不是被轮椅束缚的”。我并没有真的被绑在这个东西上。我是轮椅使用者，这真的留在了我的脑海里。但这仍然是
that we hear reasonably often. So thank you for letting us really connect to that still something that we hear reasonably often. So thank you for letting us really connect to that idea again, that that's not okay. And I think disability is something that most people will experience, but very few people are comfortable with experiencing. And there's a few reasons for that i think i think part of it is because we start to see our own morality we start to see that actually people do uh kind of change over over our lifetimes people do go through different things and and you know some of these things can be really big and powerful and a little bit scary um part of
我们经常听到的说法。所以谢谢你让我们再次与那个想法建立联系，即那种说法是不对的。我认为残疾是大多数人都会经历的事情，但很少有人能坦然面对。我认为有几个原因，我认为部分原因是，我们开始看到我们自己的道德，我们开始看到实际上人们确实会在我们的一生中发生变化，人们确实会经历不同的事情，你知道，其中一些事情可能是非常巨大、强大且有点可怕的。部分
that is the educational system that we all kind of grow up in. And part of it is just why the society doesn't accept it without getting too political. I don't think it helps with the kind of current, current governments and the kind of stuff that they've been saying recently in particular. I mean, to kind of call out people with disabilities
原因是我们在其中成长的教育体系。部分原因是社会为什么不接受它，而不谈论太多政治。我不认为这有什么帮助，特别是考虑到当前的政府以及他们最近所说的那种事情。我的意思是，去指责残疾人
specifically as not being able to work isn't the problem. It's the wider societal and kind of workplace situation that, yeah, you just need there to be the jobs, the opportunities out there. And I think all of that stuff, and we kind of hear different terminology across different kind different pockets of people that are getting discriminated against. And you can hear institutional racism, for example. And I very much think that there is also institutional ableism. And ableism is effectively the kind of derogatory kind of thought of feeling against somebody that's got
不能工作并不是问题所在。问题在于更广泛的社会和工作场所状况。是的，你只需要有工作，有就业机会。我认为所有这些事情，我们在不同群体中听到不同的术语，他们正在受到歧视。你可以听到“制度性种族主义”，例如。我非常认为也存在“制度性能力歧视”。能力歧视实际上是对残疾人的贬低性想法或感觉，以及与之相关的负面待遇。
a disability and the kind of negative treatment that's associated with that um and there's there's all this stuff that's kind of in the background that that kind of limits people that then makes people think that as soon as you're listed as somebody that's disabled and by the way you're not actually listed anywhere as disabled um but once you've kind of got that that kind of badge against you that that your life is over it it's not there is there is no there's no that's it you're done um and i think when you start to understand that yeah one people go through bad things and they come out the other side. Usually when you've been through something, you do change. Your experiences change you.
所有这些背景下的东西限制了人们，这让人们认为一旦你被列为残疾人——顺便说一句，你并没有在任何地方被列为残疾人——但一旦你有了那个标签，你的生活就结束了。不是这样的，没有那种事，你完了。我认为当你开始理解，是的，人们经历糟糕的事情，然后从另一边走出来。通常当你经历过某事时，你确实会改变。你的经历改变了你。
They transform you into the person that you're growing up to be. That's just the lives that we go through. And some of those experiences are really, really big and chunky. Some are kind of less so the really big chunky ones you you you go through the the processes and for me some of that was grief over the person i thought i was going to be that the kind of grief of of my my the person i was the day before and the and the next day was was kind of different because it's really quick acceleration, that kind of 2020, 2022 period, sorry.
它们把你塑造成你正在成长为的那个人。这就是我们经历的生活。其中一些经历非常非常巨大且沉重。有些则不那么沉重。那些非常巨大沉重的经历，你经历了这些过程。对我来说，其中一部分是对我以为我会成为的那种人的哀悼，那种我前一天还是的人，和第二天的人，有点不同，因为这是一种非常快速的加速，那段 2020 到 2022 年的时期，抱歉。
So you go through all these things, but ultimately you're still fundamentally the same person just with different life experiences. And you're no better, you're no worse. You just are you. As soon as we get to accept that more broadly, I actually think the conversation about disability will really change very quickly and the support that sits around that will also change.
所以你经历了所有这些事情，但归根结底，你本质上还是同一个人，只是有了不同的生活经历。你没有变得更好，也没有变得更糟。你只是你自己。一旦我们更广泛地接受这一点，我实际上认为关于残疾的对话会很快改变，围绕它的支持也会改变。
It is one of the fears that I've got around kind of going into a new career and kind of what that might look like as a wheelchair user and kind of needing that little bit of extra support. There is always that degree of kind of fear over will there be that support? I mean, the slight advantage that I've now got is that i i know how to fight for it um and i know that i i am allowed to kind of have that that kind of uh those reasonable adjustments to use the the kind of um the specific terminology um so it was a bit of fear but a trepidation there uh for me kind of moving into it and ultimately the good for me will will always outweigh the the
这是我对于进入新职业以及作为轮椅使用者可能会是什么样子，以及需要那一点额外支持所产生的恐惧之一。总是存在一定程度的恐惧：会有那种支持吗？我的意思是，我现在有一点点优势，我知道如何为它争取，我知道我有权拥有那种“合理调整”——使用这种特定术语。所以对我来说，进入这个领域有一点恐惧和不安，但最终，对我来说，好处总是会超过
kind of negatives that that could come from it thank you and i yeah i love that idea of there is no actual register and i think it reminded me of when i was at secondary school and it used to be said oh so you'll end up on your permanent record you don't want that and then you get to the end of secondary school and you're like there was no such thing as a permanent record i've been like to it's it's funny because i i thought that there was uh a list somewhere of people with disabilities because you can see the stats and you can see that there are x amount of people so slightly differing figures but roughly 23 of the population has some form of disability and that's got to come from somewhere so that those kind of stats that sit around that
可能带来的负面影响。谢谢，我喜欢那个“没有实际登记册”的想法。这让我想起我在中学时，人们常说：“哦，这会进入你的永久记录，你不会想要那样的。”然后当你中学毕业时，你会发现根本没有所谓的“永久记录”。这很有趣，因为我以为有一个残疾人名单，因为你可以看到统计数据，你可以看到有 X 数量的人，所以数据略有不同，但大约 23% 的人口有某种形式的残疾，这一定是有来源的。所以那些围绕它的统计数据，
and as psychologists and aspiring psychologists we do like that we like to understand these things but there isn't a specific list that says gavin clark is disabled that just doesn't exist i genuinely thought that there was and as soon as i said i was that i was disabled that was it i was going to be on a list somewhere um but there just isn't doesn't exist but you can register for some additional support with things like energy companies and things can't you and even the kind of the role that you're doing currently is for people with additional needs so you can kind of flag yourself as perhaps needing some additional support or consideration
作为心理学家和有抱负的心理学家，我们确实喜欢那样，我们喜欢理解这些事情。但并没有一个特定的名单说“Gavin Clark 是残疾人”，那根本不存在。我真的以为有，一旦我说我是残疾人，那就是了，我会被列入某个名单。但根本不存在。但是你可以为一些额外支持进行登记，比如能源公司之类的，对吧？甚至你目前所做的角色也是为有额外需求的人服务的，所以你可以标记自己可能需要一些额外的支持或考虑。
exactly so there is a kind of plethora of support out there, not always easy to access. And that kind of keeps me in a job at the moment because it's about finding easier or simpler ways to access that support and making sure that that's being followed through. There is a lot out there. There's ranging from something called personal independence payment, which is a I don't like the word benefit but a kind of extra payment that people with disabilities um can potentially get i stress that because actually most disabled people don't get it um it's it's quite difficult to go through the process for yeah so so pip um is this this kind of benefit um this payment that you get
完全正确。所以确实有大量的支持，但并不总是容易获得。这正是让我目前有工作的原因，因为它是关于寻找更容易或更简单的方法来获得这种支持，并确保它得到落实。外面有很多东西。从所谓的“个人独立补助金”（PIP）开始，我不喜欢“福利”这个词，但它是一种残疾人可能获得的额外补助。我强调这一点，因为实际上大多数残疾人并没有得到它，经历这个过程非常困难。所以 PIP 是这种福利，这种你获得的补助，
that has two components uh one is a mobility your daily living um component and one is the the kind of pure mobility side so you have to go through loads of tests and and uh and filling out ridiculously large documents, kind of explaining how your conditions impact the way that you live your life. And the nature of that is to try and bridge some of the gap. It doesn't get anywhere near the real gap of how much more it costs to live with a disability. So the latest figures, so Scopa, which is a disability charity, came out earlier this year with the kind of latest figures, and it's around about £975 a month more expensive to live with a disability. So that's just for me to get out of bed and just live my normal life it's it's
它有两个组成部分，一个是移动或日常生活部分，另一个是纯粹的移动方面。所以你必须经历大量的测试，填写极其庞大的文件，解释你的状况如何影响你的生活方式。其本质是试图弥补一些差距。它根本无法弥补残疾生活成本的真实差距。所以最新的数据，Scope（一家残疾人慈善机构）今年早些时候发布了最新数据，残疾生活每月大约要多花 975 英镑。所以这只是为了让我起床并过上正常生活，
roughly um that a month if you have one disabled person in the household obviously that then increases if you've got if you've got more than one and there's some slight fluctuations if it's a child rather than an adult but broadly we're talking about about that mark the maximum that you can get with pip is around about 745 pounds i think from memory so there's there's a kind of an element of that i don't know anyone that actually gets the whole amount um most people don't um but it helps you with things like getting access to motability which is great for someone to get a car potentially, or it might not be a car, but it might be a mobility scooter
如果家里有一个残疾人，大约是这么多。当然，如果你有一个以上，这个数字就会增加。如果是儿童而不是成人，会有一些轻微的波动，但大体上我们谈论的是那个数字。PIP 最高能获得的金额大约是 745 英镑，我记得是这样。所以有一个因素，我不认识任何真正获得全额的人，大多数人都没有。但这有助于你获得诸如“Motability”之类的服务，这对某人获得汽车可能很有帮助，或者可能不是汽车，而是代步车，
that just bridges some of that cost because these things are obscenely expensive. My wheelchair, so I've just got another one on the way actually, but my wheelchair was just over 8,000 pounds for the one wheelchair my next one is about seven and a half thousand pounds um and then i also play wheelchair basketball so that's about another four and a half thousand pounds um and that's just for me to
这弥补了部分成本，因为这些东西极其昂贵。我的轮椅，我实际上刚订了另一辆，但我的轮椅花了 8000 多英镑，下一辆大约是 7500 英镑。然后我还打轮椅篮球，那大约又是 4500 英镑。这只是为了让我
get from one place to the next um so there's a lot of costs um kind of associated with kind of living with it but there is support out there lots of great charities and then there is this thing called reasonable adjustments which is both in the employer employee relationship as well as in the service and and and patient or or customer perspective that as a disabled person you are protected under the Equality Act that you cannot be discriminated against that you have a right for reasonable adjustments and there's always been a debate over what that looks like and what that might mean to allow you to have the same experience that's important to to kind of realize that it's not an enhanced experience it's the same experience as anybody
从一个地方到另一个地方。所以有很多与生活相关的成本。但确实有支持，有很多很棒的慈善机构。然后还有所谓的“合理调整”，这既存在于雇主与雇员的关系中，也存在于服务与患者或客户的视角中。作为残疾人，你受到《平等法》的保护，你不能受到歧视，你有权获得合理调整。关于这看起来是什么样子，以及为了让你拥有相同的体验意味着什么，一直存在争论。重要的是要意识到，这不是一种“增强”的体验，而是与任何
that doesn't have um a disability so with work um that gets me things like the chair that i'm sat on currently um so it's a slightly different chair. It's got some slightly different adjustments than a normal chair and work brought me that. It might also be that I work from home more than others do because travelling into the office can be quite a big ask for me at the moment. Or it might be something as simple as some software on your computer. And you also get that when you're studying as well.
没有残疾的人相同的体验。所以在工作中，这为我带来了诸如我现在坐的椅子之类的东西。它是一把稍微不同的椅子，比普通椅子有一些不同的调整，公司为我买了它。也可能是因为我比其他人更多地在家工作，因为目前去办公室对我来说是一个很大的要求。或者可能只是电脑上的一些软件。你在学习时也会得到这些。
So there's the disability allowance that you get, disability support allowance, which is basically through student finance. And that will help pay for some of the things that you might need that again because of being disabled you might need to to i don't print something out because you can't sit and stare at a screen because you get chronic migraines as an example or it could be that you have kind of support to get from um to uh in and out of um university um and kind of some support for additional um kind of transport costs because most normal transport you you actually can't use because they haven't got wheelchair access in in most vehicles um yeah or a suede of other things um so there is lots of support uh it can be a bit
所以你有残疾津贴，残疾支持津贴，这基本上是通过学生贷款公司提供的。它将帮助支付你可能需要的一些东西，因为残疾，你可能需要打印某些东西，因为你不能坐着盯着屏幕，因为你会患慢性偏头痛，作为一个例子。或者可能是你有支持往返大学，以及一些额外的交通费用支持，因为大多数普通交通工具你实际上无法使用，因为它们在大多数车辆中没有轮椅通道。是的，或者其他一系列事情。所以有很多支持，
grueling to access it um but particularly in the university context actually most universities have got a really good student support centers that will help you through that process as well um i think the most difficult about it part about it is knowing that these things exist, because I didn't even know that PIP existed up until last year. Thank you so much for helping our audience learn more about complex regional pain syndrome, living with that, being a wheelchair user, letting us think more about ableism, letting us think more about some of the struggles that a wheelchair user or someone with additional physical health needs might have as they navigate their career in mental health so thank you could you tell us a little bit about your podcast if that's okay before we finish yeah of course so
获得它可能有点令人筋疲力尽，但特别是在大学环境中，实际上大多数大学都有非常好的学生支持中心，也会帮助你完成那个过程。我认为最困难的部分是知道这些东西的存在，因为直到去年我才知道 PIP 的存在。非常感谢你帮助我们的听众更多地了解复杂区域疼痛综合征，了解与之共存，作为轮椅使用者的生活，让我们更多地思考能力歧视，让我们更多地思考轮椅使用者或有额外身体健康需求的人在心理健康领域发展职业时可能遇到的一些挣扎。所以谢谢你。在我们结束之前，你能简单介绍一下你的播客吗？如果可以的话。好的，当然。
i've got two uh i've got the the safe place podcast which uh you'll hear my kind of dulcet tones uh on that as the host uh there's a mixture of episodes there's there's me sharing some of my own experiences which is kind of the the first season then season two and and the upcoming season three uh goes into more of of guests and you'll hear from people across the board. We've got pain psychologists on there. We've got CEOs of organizations. And we've also got people that just experienced their own mental health conditions and wanted to share their own experiences. So it's a real comforting zone that was kind of built out of me feeling like I needed a space to kind of think about my own life experiences
我有两个播客。我有《Safe Place》播客，你会听到我作为主持人的声音。那里有各种各样的节目，有我分享自己的一些经历，这是第一季，然后第二季和即将到来的第三季会邀请更多的嘉宾，你会听到来自各行各业的人。我们有疼痛心理学家，有组织首席执行官，还有那些经历过自己的心理健康状况并想分享自己经历的人。所以这是一个真正舒适的区域，建立它是出于我觉得我需要一个空间来思考我自己的生活经历，
and how that was kind of impacting me. And then the Disabling Me podcast is brand new. You'd have to look for it at the moment. It's currently on YouTube only, but we're going to be releasing that properly in a kind of more of a kind of formal launch over the coming weeks. And that is really a kind of social conversation on how living with disabilities can be frustrating, can be wonderful, but also how society
以及那对我有什么影响。然后《Disabling Me》播客是全新的。你现在必须去搜索它。它目前仅在 YouTube 上，但我们将在未来几周内以更正式的方式发布。那真的是一场关于残疾生活如何令人沮丧、如何美妙，但也关于社会
kind of gets in the way sometimes and thinking about some of the things that we can do to improve that too. Thank you so much. And was it your podcasting that landed you on the Disability Power 100 2023 list? It was, yeah. So that was for the Safe Place podcast. A few other little bits that I do in the background, which I should probably give away time, but I never do.
有时如何阻碍我们，以及思考我们可以做些什么来改善这些问题的社会对话。非常感谢。是你的播客让你进入了 2023 年“残疾人权力 100 强”名单吗？是的，确实是。那是为了《Safe Place》播客。还有我在幕后做的其他一些小事，我应该花时间去宣传，但我从不这样做。
Um, because I get a little bit kind of shy and, and, uh, and don't like talking about myself too much. Um, but yeah, that was that, that was for, for the podcast, for types of guests that was having on and just really bringing, bringing more of a voice to people with, uh, with disabilities. Thank you. So thank you so thank you so much for your time um and yeah if people want to reach out to you on social media where's the best place for them to do that so your best bet is uh either through linkedin and you can you can find
因为我有点害羞，不喜欢谈论自己太多。但是的，那是为了播客，为了我邀请的嘉宾类型，以及真正为残疾人带来更多的声音。谢谢。非常感谢你的时间。如果人们想在社交媒体上联系你，最好的方式是什么？最好的方式是要么通过 LinkedIn，你可以找到
me uh gavin clark and i'm sure we can put a kind of link to that in the show notes or you can find me on Instagram which is I am Gavin Clark I will just caveat that I do tend to change my name on on Instagram now and again but it generally is I am Gavin Clark which you can find me at and you are Clark with an E for anybody that might not be watching this on YouTube. Perfect. Thank you again for your time. And if anyone didn't catch our previous episode where we were looking together
我，Gavin Clark，我相信我们可以在节目说明中放一个链接。或者你可以在 Instagram 上找到我，是 I am Gavin Clark。我得提醒一下，我现在偶尔会改 Instagram 上的名字，但通常是 I am Gavin Clark，你可以在那里找到我。而且 Clark 的 Clark 是带 E 的，给那些可能没有在 YouTube 上观看的人。太棒了。再次感谢你的时间。如果有人没听我们上一期关于
at studying for conversion masters, then we'd absolutely recommend that you check that out. Definitely. Thank you again for your time, Gavin. Thank you, Mariannene all the pleasure welcome back along I hope you found that interesting I certainly found that it helped flesh out some of my knowledge-based gaps so I hope you found the same too I'd love to know what you thought to this episode come along to the aspiring psychologist community and let me know please do bear in mind
攻读转换硕士课程的节目，我们绝对建议你去听听。当然。再次感谢你的时间，Gavin。谢谢，Marianne。很高兴欢迎大家回来。希望你觉得这期节目很有趣，我当然觉得它帮助充实了我的一些知识空白，所以希望你也一样。我很想知道你对这期节目的看法，来《Aspiring Psychologist》社区告诉我。请务必记住
that the aspiring psychologist membership is a wonderfully nourishing enriching compassionate space that helps you grow and helps you to achieve your potential but the peer support in that membership is also off the scale so if you are feeling like your journey is a little bit singular at the moment and you'd welcome some buddies come on in which you can do from just 30 pounds a month there's details in the show notes or you can always dm me for a link and i will ping that across to you please do also check out the books the clinical psychologist collective book the aspiring psychologist collective book and the podcast is an ever great resource bling a few likes around and tell your friends. Forward the links that you think
“有抱负的心理学家”会员是一个非常滋养、丰富且充满同理心的空间，它能帮助你成长并发挥你的潜能。会员内部的同伴支持更是超乎想象。如果你觉得目前的旅程有些孤单，欢迎加入我们，每月仅需30英镑。详细信息请查看节目说明，或者直接私信我获取链接，我会发给你。也请务必看看《临床心理学家集体》和《有抱负的心理学家集体》这两本书。本播客也是一个非常棒的资源，请点赞并分享给你的朋友们。转发你认为
are really great links. And thank you in advance if you do do that. I will be along with the next episode of the podcast on 6am on Monday. Thank you so much for being part of my world and I'll see you very soon. Take care. I'm a psychologist. And let this be your guide.
非常棒的链接。如果你能这样做，我提前表示感谢。下期播客将于周一早上6点发布。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分，我们很快再见。保重。我是一名心理学家，让这成为你的指南。
With this podcast at your side, you'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast. With Dr. Marianne Trent. My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a
有这个播客陪伴，你离获得资格就不远了。这是《有抱负的心理学家播客》，我是玛丽安·特伦特博士。我叫贾娜，是一名心理健康从业者实习生。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。书中关于不同故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容让我觉得非常有趣。各种各样的途径让我感到惊讶，成为临床心理学家并没有所谓的“完美路径”，这让我充满信心，觉得自己并没有走错路，也减轻了我的压力。所以，如果你感到
bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
对成为临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦开始读，你就停不下来。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。